[Music]
all
beat simone i bar astra generation ship
ago but we have about 250 300 sheep that
we produce milk of this part of
this milk we use it to make
cheese case born for him minsk c
reggina do business wire springer
fresh in  about forty days the
form will be completely invaded by the
dairy fly of its larvae
[Music]
with a spicy taste and a different
flavor pasty taste yard at work doing the
fine
[Music]
according to some the verne continues lives
inside it is not so if  we will not be
feet because we have been eating it for a lifetime
[Music]
simone those who are still fit
but I have always known him mine did not
know him and not my uncles and
chernoff cheese March ham
a slice of melon and death  his